the Joe Rogan experience but if you have
a complete lack of ability to
communicate sincerely that's not being
hip or cool right that's a defense
mechanism and it's a stupid one because
you don't have much time
you have a hundred years if you're lucky
they go by like that if you have a
hundred dollars you spend a dollar a day
before you know what you're [ __ ]
broke that's life
my son was like why did Michael how old
was Michael Jackson when he died I was
like guy in his 50s he was like oh okay
like that like that sounded right to him
I'm like people don't die in so much
like basically that's me well Michael
Jackson's a craziest case of all time
right because he was given and they was
in administering anesthesia every night
so he can go to sleep dude
I was playing that I was playing I want
to be starting something and Thriller in
the car on the way taking my son to
school and I start crying just because
it's like how do you explain what he was
and how monumental what he did was like
I can remember seeing him dancing the
Billie Jean and like how kind of like
broke the mold for music and the persona
that he had and that level of creativity
yeah I was weird and then to be in the
car with us with my kid who doesn't
really knows the name but didn't you
know right it's just that's not part of
his look that's not part of his life
maybe she introduced him to that movie
that documentary was that one
documentary they did this is it yeah
oh yeah yeah does that get into the
drugs and stuff and how many years was
he doing that for so sad not very long
but here's one of the more fucked-up
things this is something I speculated a
long time ago his doctor who went to
jail for giving him the anesthesia also
testified that Michael Jackson was
chemically castrated by his parents when
he was young to preserve his voice
that's what I suspected I suspected I
talked about on the podcast like years
ago I was saying this I think he was a
castrato which is they take young boys
and they used to do this with opera and
they would castrate them at a very
and because of that their body never
developed testosterone so they would
develop this high piercing like haunting
voice it's very strange like we played
some of the there is only a few
recordings of actual cast Radha's that
are available orchestra' toes one of
those but the when you play on their
haunting because you realize like this
is a kid that was castrated as a baby so
they could be a singer like this is
[ __ ] up and that's what Michael
Jackson's doctor said they did to
Michael they did it through chemicals
they chemically castrated him the same
in his argument is I'm just trying to
regulate a situation that was already
far gone is that his defense no I mean
there's no defense the doctors just
[ __ ] you know he's just he killed I
mean killed Michael Jackson let him get
anesthesia until he died his defense
wasn't that he was just saying there's
something else right like Michael
Jackson was [ __ ] up like his parents
literally chemically castrated him to
preserve his voice because he was the
lead singer of the Jackson 5 when he was
a baby and that was part of what was
great about him was like Oh baby give me
one more chance like that voice all set
oh there that voice was nothing like
anything that he would be capable of
doing as an adult if he grew into a man
he would have this big old man I want to
get some [ __ ] voice Michael he would
have like a you know a Barry White voice
or something like [ __ ] you can't have
that like you're Michael you know your
ABC well he may not have gotten that
deep of his voice but I guess if you
think that that's to bleep be believed
that he'd never had the chance
I believe it you know why I believe it
cuz his voice didn't sound anything like
a regular man's it didn't sound anything
like his brothers his brothers all look
like regular grown-ass men Michael
Johnson's deep voice
[Music]
that's not deep so that's that cold
that's like rain gee I was looking it up
all those places I'm seeing that story
about him being castrated hurling
tabloids the Sun and that kind of stuff
right but it was wasn't it an interview
in like the which it was a UK paper and
I just grew but it was the Sun which is
like not the best mmm this is not the
worst right The Daily Mail's the worse
both of them actual are they're the same
they equal yeah I don't think so I'm
hoping that's so true last time you
talked about this I got some messages I
don't know again like was getting videos
like this of showing like examples of
his deep talking voices see that's not
deep there's a lot of chicks that have
weighed deeper voices yeah listen that's
his deep voice come on let me tell you
about the [ __ ] you listen to the wrong
people huh I mean think of how many
women have ruthlessly deep voices I
think I think they did to him his voice
was just phenomenal a human nature like
as an adult that is such a [ __ ]
phenomenal song it doesn't sound like
anything that a regular man is capable
of singing like the notes that he hits
like that voice that he had was just
haunting right trying to think of who
else is a natural who star who has a
high voice Oh Prince used to sing in
falsetto but it was very obvious when he
was doing it that he was doing it yes
whereas Michael Jackson like that human
nature song was one of my favorites
because it's such a like a slow smooth
holding of those sounds these are
natural sounds that are coming from them
you know it's like this natural like
warm affectionate tone to it it just
doesn't seem like a man's voice it
doesn't seem like a woman's voice either
you got the right wave talking that's
different that's like falsetto Hanson
are you saying that's like a four sounds
like a caricature yeah you could say
that in that way what does this feel
like dancing oh puber phony a-- known as
mutation
it's a type of voice disorder
characterized by habitual use of
high-pitched voice after puberty oh so
that some people get that yeah
psychogenic in nature yeah the other
thing is you look at his body had no
muscle like his body was like you mean
he was a very act of God dancing all the
time but it wasn't built like a dancer
he was built like a stick you know it
was a very very thin guy that's what you
would expect from someone who didn't
have any testosterone you wouldn't be
able to develop any muscle I'm sticking
with my theory I might have biases but
they're mine they're mine
okay I'm sticking with it dig them up
dig them up and check the nuts take em
up
[Applause]